if you're trying to make sure you brush your teeth for two minutes
this toothbrush from the TikTok shop is the best
it's got a ton of different settings
but what happens is it only vibrates
it does all the sonic movements and everything for 30 seconds
and then wait for it
it'll give a little pause so that you can go to the next section of your mouth
so that you can brush your teeth for 30 seconds
when you feel the pause
you know to move on to the other section of your mouth
you feel the pause
you go move to the next section of your mouth
you feel the pause again
and you go to the last section of your mouth
and the toothbrush automatically turns off
did you hear that
so now you would move to the next section
so if you're having a hard time brushing your teeth for two minutes
and you really wanna take care of your teeth
which you should
this is the toothbrush
it's right here in the TikTok shop